-I'm so happy to see you,
as always.
Little Marlowe, your daughter,
is so beautiful and cute
backstage.
-Staying up late
on a school night.
-I know, my gosh.
-Couldn't keep her away.
-Oh, I'm so happy, yeah.
And I'm so happy we had puppies
here so that she could play with
the puppies, too.
It's Nana Week here,
so we're actually asking anyone
if they have
any grandma stories.
And you have a very interesting
story of your grandma.
-Well, it's actually my mum. I
didn't know one of my grannies.
The other one lived in South
Africa, but my mother started
the first ever exercise-based
school in England in the '70s.
-First ever exercise-based
school.
-Yes, and it was called
Granny's Beautiful Bodies.
-Yeah.
-That's my granny story.
-Yeah, your mom was
Granny's Beautiful Bodies.
-But she was not a granny.
She's a granny now.
Gan-Gan.
-Oh, that's the name?
-Gan-Gan.
-Everyone's got a name.
-We've got a Gaga and a Gan-Gan.
-Oh, Gaga and a Gan-Gan.
-Gaga and Gan-Gan.
-♪ Oh, gaga da gang gang gong
gida gangy gong gong ♪
♪ Gang gang gong gong gang
gang gong gong gang gang ♪
What was the school about?
-I love this stuff.
-I know.
-What was the school?
So it was this very -- It was
kind of like
a yoga/Alexander Technique
combo, ballet, balletic.
But like Albert Finney went
and Ava Gardner.
It was super glam.
-Wow.
-Yeah. She was really good.
-And did you ever take
any classes?
-Never. Not once.
-No, of course not.
-But actually, you know what?
So she had the school and then
they had kids and they sort of
moved away.
And then when I was a teenager,
she set up --
she decided to start
teaching classes again.
So she'd have these women -- I
was just like a moody teenager
in my room, and there would be
these women next door, like,
going --
[ Breathing heavily ]
You know, stretching and doing
the stuff.
And then it was so popular that
they'd be out in the landing
and I was this horrible
14-year-old with a hoodie on
and I'd just climb over these
women with their legs in the air
to go to the loo and, like,
slam the door.
-"Get out of my house!"
-They still came.
She was obviously that good.
But no, I've never done
one class with her.
-I wanted to ask you
because you just recently
celebrated a milestone birthday.
-Yeah. 21.
-21.
[ Laughter ]
Wow, congratulations.
You can have alcohol if you want
to try, you can do it.
What is it, 40?
-No, 21.
-That's right, yes.
[ Laughter ]
-What is wrong with you?
-I don't know.
"What is wrong with you?
Why do you keep saying 40?"
-I turned 40.
What's the matter with you?
-What is wrong with me? Come on.
-I am 40 years old.
-Did you celebrate?
Did you have a party?
-I have the worst birthday.
I'm born on
the 28th of December,
which I was driving
actually this year
and the radio man said, "And
here we are in the black hole
between Christmas and New Year,
the 28th of December."
-[ Crying ]
Happy birthday to me!
-No one's ever put it
like that before.
But it's true. It's the whole
excitement, and then Boxing Day,
and then the 27th,
you're starting to get low.
By the 28th, you're like --
you're down.
You're down. And then I'm --
Yeah, I'm the loser that
then has to, like, open presents
again in front of people.
The whole thing is,
like, mortifying,
so I never have a party,
although I was peer-pressured
to organize one extensively
that I had to cancel [Cackles]
because of omicron.
Not that that's
a good thing but...
Yeah, but it was ripping through
England and I had organized
a 1920s birthday party
for the "Roaring Twenties"
that we have been enjoying.
-Yeah, right.
-Yeah.
-But wait.
There's something satisfying
about canceling plans.
-Actually, my best friend and I
had an idea to set up a company
where we extensively and
vigorously plan an event for you
that is incredibly stressful and
we cancel it the night before.
[ Laughter ]
-So you can just relax
and you're like,
"Ah, let's just have
a glass of wine."
-The feeling of like --
Anyone who cancels on me
is my favorite person.
[ Laughter ]
And I guess it's my age.
-That's so funny.
-I don't want ever
to do anything.
-That is so funny.
Do you remember celebrating
your birthday
when we did a movie together?
"Factory Girl"?
-Yes.
-Yeah.
-You ate my face.
On a cake. On a cake.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, we'll be right back.
No, I had your --
-Yes.
-Yes, I had your --
-My face was on a cake.
-Yes, we put a giant --
-You did not eat my face.
-But technically I guess we --
-You did go for the face.
-Yeah, I did.
I thought that'd be funny.
-Yeah, because
you're a funny guy.
-Well, I thought
that was very --
It was a nice, glamorous shot
of you.
-It was not the prettiest
picture, was it?
They had found a picture of me
that was a wardrobe test photo
that had been leaked from
"G.I. Joe."
Like, not even
an officially approved --
Someone had, like, leaked
a bad one.
I had, like, the wrong hair and,
like, black leather --
Holly Wiersma,
our great producer.
-Was it?
-I think she got the cake.
-Yeah, and so she wanted to make
sure you had the best --
-So we ate an ugly picture
of me, yeah.
The time of our lives.
That was my college years.
-It was, right?
-Shreveport, Louisiana.
-We had the best time together,
yeah.
But now look, we're parents.
-Now we're 21 and getting older.
-You're 21 years old and wow.
-The good old days.
-Yeah.
Marlowe is so fun.
Here's what my question for you.
What do you play for her?
She's 10 years old?
-So, we used to do this thing
when I drove her to school.
We now live in New York
and there's a school bus. Yes.
But in England, I used to drive
her to school,
and I decided to do, like,
an album a week
to musically educate
my 3-year-old at the time.
-Did it work?
-I think so.
-Yeah, that's good.
-I mean, I have no say
in what she listens to now,
but back then we did like
pet sounds
and we did the Smiths.
She used to sing like,
"Happiness is a Warm Gun"
at three, which is funny.
-Yeah, exactly.
We tried --
We try to sneak those in
and then they just kind of
went to their own area.
-What do they --
What are they into?
-They're into, like,
hard-core metal, heavy metal.
[ Laughter ]
I want to talk about
"Anatomy of a Scandal."
-Or a sandal.
That's what we called it on set.
-Academy -- Anatomy of a S--
-Academy of a Sandal.
-Academy of Sandals.
And the sandal goes to --
[ Laughter ]
"Anatomy of a Scandal."
-Yes.
-David E. Kelley.
-Yeah.
-Not too shabby.
The guy can write.
We'll give him that.
-Oh, my gosh.
-He co-wrote it
with Melissa James Gibson,
who is also a sublime writer.
-And you told me that you --
Currently, you worked with
one of the biggest stars you've
ever worked with in your career.
-Yeah.
-Now, this is --
I mean, you've worked with me.
-Yeah.
-And you're saying --
-Yeah, yeah.
-You're saying
this is a bigger moment.
-Bradley Cooper, Clint Eastwood.
But whatever because I worked
with Peppa Pig.
[ Laughter ]
Amelie.
-Amelie Bea Smith.
This is the voice of Peppa Pig?
-That is the voice of Peppa Pig.
And I've never fangirled out
on anyone.
Like, it was just --
It was really too much.
I'd sit there across set with
my cup sort of staring at her.
And then make her FaceTime
my daughter relentlessly,
and she was such a pro,
you know? She was like nine.
-You're like,
"Just say 'muddy puddles!'
Say 'muddy puddles!'"
-Yeah, exactly, exactly.
I have all these voice notes.
Like, "Hello, Marlowe.
This Is --"
I was like, "Yes!"
-That's why we work so hard,
to get to this spot.
-Exactly.
-How do we set up the series?
-So, this series is --
It's the people that did
"Big Little Lies"
and "The Undoing,"
and it's that six-part format --
-I love both of them.
I love both of them. Come on.
-They didn't even play for that
because it's such a crush.
-Oh, it's such a crush.
-So, these people know
how to do this, and this one is
about a sort of --
I'm the wife of
a Tory politician in England
who is caught having an affair
and it evolves into
all sorts of drama.
It's Michelle Dockery, costars
Naomi Scott, Rupert Friend.
This scene I think is
when the bomb is dropped.
-Yeah, and he has to tell you
before the scandal gets out,
"Hey, this happened.
I had an affair."
-Yeah.
-"So let's squash this.
Let's figure this out
before it gets --
It's going to be out
in the press.
It's going to be everywhere.
I just want you to know."
-It was, like,
such a horrible moment.
I'm sure many people have
experienced that moment of,
like, this thing has happened,
and my heartbeat
started to go up,
and I had a microphone on,
and they could hear
my heartbeat accelerating
on the cans when they were
watching the monitor.
-Really?
-And they've actually --
So, they kept that in
and then they use it
as a motif thing
throughout the show.
My little heartbeat.
-Your heartbeat is in the scene?
-Yeah, that's how I act.
-Come on.
That's how Sienna Miller --
You don't mess with
Sienna Miller, man.
She'll tell you what's up.
Put the mike by the heart.
"I'll make the heart -- How loud
do you want the heartbeat?
I can do it."
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Sienna Miller
in "Anatomy of a Scandal."
Take a look.
[ Heart beating ]
-There's more.
You're not telling me just to
tell me, to unburden yourself.
There's more.
Is she pregnant?
-No. God, no.
This story is about to break.
-When?
-Tonight.
The Mail is splashing it
tomorrow, online late tonight.
Chris Clark's on his way over.
-He's coming here? Now?
-We have to get ahead of this.
-We have to figure out how to
protect our children from it.
-We have to do both.
-[ Imitating heartbeat ]
-Sienna Miller!
"Anatomy of a Scandal" begins
streaming April 15th on Netflix.